where did you say it on Instagram or
something that you just cut off all your
hair and you're going through some sort
of mental health phase like a depressive
kind of situation what's going on I cut
all the the trauma out of my hair what
trauma did you cut out of your hair I
think this year um has well for a lot of
people not just me just a lot of people
that are close to me have gone through
it I don't know it's just I've known so
many people that have gone through
breakups or divorces or you went through
a divorce this year right was it this
year or it's going oh it's still going
oh hey that's the worst are you dating
yet no um I I would like this to sort of
wrap up I I I don't have the head space
for that uh yet but I'm I'm riding so
much right now that's kind of been my my
way of dating is just through song um
but have You' been and you've been
severely depressed no not severely like
I I haven't seen you since 2019 but I've
had my son since then in 2020 so I've
been very public about postpartum
depression which was something I dealt
with uh in 2020 along with probably
circumstantial 2020 depression too but
um no I'm I'm out of all of that um I
think I I don't I don't know if it's
just meeting the other side and that's
what this year was was 2022 it felt like
a lot of things went semi back to normal
I went on tour and then this year we're
on the other side of that one and I just
I think that's why there's so much
change and transformation happening what
happened in your postpartum depression
did you did you get so low that not that
you'd want to kill yourself or something
but but like you couldn't get out of bed
not quite to that extent I think I was
just starting to make like very little
sense to myself and to people around me
feeling
useless uh I mean I felt useless in the
way of I couldn't work I couldn't tour
everything got cancelled so that was you
know partially when at the time and I'm
still working through this therapy is
like attaching your entire identity to
what you do for a living um which is not
good that's join the club yeah it's it's
it's a tough one when you've done
something for so long to not think that
that's you even though you love it and
it makes you a living uh that's that's
not who you are so separating those
things um was helpful uh getting on
Zoloft was also really cool oh no
kidding you went on are you still on it
uh no I was on it for about a year and
what did that do it just lifted you out
of the depression yeah it's it's like
you're living in the the the negative
the red for a long time without
realizing it that your your supply is so
depleted of just serotonin dopamine and
a lot of that is just chemical and you
know having the baby and I had like an
emergency C-section so there were just
like a lot of things that didn't go to
plan but everyone's okay everyone's
healthy uh but no I mean the other side
of that which I've been vocal about is
that it's it's a lot on the the the mom
and um you love your baby you're
obsessed with your baby but oh my God
your your body has been through a
violent thing and um there's of course
you're going to be affected emotionally
hormonally by
afterwards